there is one thing i think is that's
very important
provides an exit from the system and
could
protect you or at least in my opinion
will protect me and it's bitcoin
obviously
and so i really want to talk about the
story with elon musk because i think
elon musk is scamming people
that's my personal opinion elon musk is
trying to scam people
uh hey look man i i thought elon was
funny on snl
because it's funny to watch him i think
he's cool for doing a lot of things i
think tesla and spacex are awesome
but i think elon should be criticized
when he does things that are bad
and i think he's trying to rip people
off so we have the story from bloomberg
musk
sends bitcoin tumbling with shock you
turn on payments
you may have seen the tweet he said uh
tesla and bitcoin let me pull up his
tweet here i tweeted mocking him
and he said tesla has suspended vehicle
purchases using bitcoin
we are concerned about rapidly
increasing use of fossil fuels for
bitcoin mining and transactions
especially coal
which has the worst emissions of any
fuel cryptocurrency is a good idea on
many levels and we believe it is a
promising future
but this cannot come at a great ex great
cost to the environment
tesla will not be selling any bitcoin
and we intend to use it for transactions
as soon as mining transitions to more
sustainable energy we are also looking
at other cryptocurrencies that use
less than one percent of bitcoin's
energy for per transaction
he then posts this uh so that was a
couple days
that was yesterday then he posts this
energy usage trend over the past few
months is insane
and you can see bitcoin electricity
consumption has skyrocketed dramatically
the only problem harvard business review
covered this only about eight days ago
saying that there's two reports one says
39 of energy used for bitcoin
is renewable and another report says 73
is renewable why it's kind of obvious if
you have a mining operation you don't
want supply disruption you don't want to
rely on power outages
so you go to places where you have a
consistent energy supply notably
hydroelectric dams
yep where a consistent electricity
supply renewable it's not so much that
they're like i don't like carbon it's
like i want a
reliable supply of energy here's what
happens
people like elon musk he comes out and
he says
tesla will now accept bitcoin the price
skyrockets
yep then they sell a bunch make a bunch
of money and say see look
yeah then they come out and say oh oh no
the environment oh
geez oh they're using coal for
electricity oh no we gotta stop
then the price tanks back down and all
the rich people
who don't need the their assets
liquefied
say i don't care think about this way if
you're somebody who makes 500 bucks a
week
and you see what's happening with the us
dollar in buying power and you see
what's happening happening with bitcoin
you're like
i'm going to buy some bitcoin so you do
then elon musk makes this announcement
and the price drops
it's like 12 or something and you're
like i'm gonna lose 60 bucks
so you panic sell and you still end up
losing 60 bucks
because you need liquid cash in your
life you're not rich you only got a
few hundred dollars millionaires
billionaires
well they can pay their rent in their
mortgages and their car bills and still
keep millions of dollars in crypto even
when the price drops they're going to
shrug and go
i don't care and they'll buy the dip yep
that's right they'll buy the dip 100
they'll buy it back up this is how they
keep people
poor because people see elon musk and
they panic and they sell
now some people a lot of people are
getting wise to the game i remember
back when bitcoin hit 20k people were
like merging their homes
then you get news about like countries
banning bitcoin or whatever and they
panic
and they sell and they lose tons of
money and if you did
buy bitcoin and held it and it went up
to even now at 47.48 even though it's
dropped from 60
you're still double your money it's
probably going to go up
so that's why all of the smart people
are the rich people they buy the dip
but don't be surprised when you see
governments billionaires
banks make an announcement about how
they're getting rid of bitcoin
then poor people who aren't smart enough
panic and sell it and they laugh as they
buy it all back
up that's the cycle they need a way to
control the market because they control
the stock market they need the same
control over crypto and they found it
you know and i think that you're you're
right you identified something important
like elon has been great on a lot of
things
but i'm glad i have alerts set um and i
got
i got and saw that one immediately and i
was like oh this is bad this is the
worst thing he's done
in recent times in terms of his public
persona this could shift a lot of the
way people think about him
because it was very clearly he knew what
was going to happen he had to know and
if he doesn't then he should
probably shut his twitter down for a
couple days and think about it now get
this now he's saying that he's
going to be he's working with with doge
devs to fix doge
think about what he's doing he's pumping
doge he's pumping doge
he called himself the dog they called
him the doge father and snl even though
the price went down
apparently his son is mining doge it's
really really obvious dough is just
trading right now for 40 cents
meaning you can easily buy thousands
upon thousands of doge
then you get doge up to 100 bucks or
whatever you make tons of huge return
huge
huge return way more than bitcoin at
this point so there was there was a
period where
bitcoin was drop was jumping
ridiculously fast
so from november till now bitcoin's gone
up substantially like hundreds of
percent
but there was a period where it's like
it was at a dollar and it could jump to
50
that's a 50x return yeah now that
bitcoin is trading much much higher
it's it's it's harder for those swings
it's starting to stabilize right
so what happens is people start buying
alt coins
that are trading for like a fraction of
a penny
so if it's trading for the smallest
decimal point it can only double
it'll double your money so now elon's
probably in
in my opinion looking at bitcoin going
bitcoin's great
but is there a coin we can get and pump
it up really really fast
dogecoin's trading at five cents tons of
people will buy it
we can make a movement we can put out a
tweet everybody buys it
so apparently one dude became a
millionaire and like was posting about
it
yeah he had he had he had the right
amount of doge and then it broke a
certain amount and he made a million
bucks
so one of the big guys at goldman sachs
left because he made millions
yeah yep so it seems to me
like this announcement is more so he can
pump doge
but doge is inflationary there's no cap
it they produce what is it like what are
they doing 14 million per day or
something
yeah i don't know somebody i'm pretty
sure they can just keep going with it
right they can just keep going just keep
going yeah and so people are going to go
in they're going to cash out quick
and i think doge is funny i still have
thousands of doge
and i'll hold on to it because who knows
if elon musk is doing with this i'll
hold on to it i guess
but i still think i think bitcoin is
going to reach a million bucks i gotta
say
doge is trash it is absolute
useless trash as a token it may change
in the future it's not a token
or as a coin yeah whatever it's it's
gunk it has no value
functionally i disagree it only has like
monetary value it doesn't do anything
it's basically
it's an inflationary cash yeah it
doesn't have any technical value
it's better i i i i maybe it will in the
future maybe better than us
well the us dollar has zero technical
value as well yes so i'd rather have i'd
rather have doesn't use dollars too
right that's why i'm like i'm gonna keep
i'm just saying i don't want the dollars
within the closed system of crypto
let's get it out ahead of this doge is
junk i don't know why
elon's trolling people like this no i
disagree it's because of returns
it's like i mean yeah he's making and
it's the memeable it's so
memeable yes you know with the dog
that's that's the easiest to know and
he's making
people rich which is like up kind of
inverting the monetary scheme of this
consolidation of wealth to the top he's
like giving them
he's honestly making way more rich
people rich than poor people rich
honestly if i'm being real like somebody
like me
like during the dip yesterday i could
buy a bunch and make way more back on my
return
in terms of spending power than somebody
who makes 500 a week or something you
know we
we talked about this like last week that
there are programs that automatically
buy and sell
yeah so imagine this uh elon announces
the bitcoin thing and the price dropped
like 47.
it dropped so low it probably triggered
a bunch of people to auto buy
it jumped back up to like 51. then what
started going down it triggered an auto
sell
so people right then were making three
grand per coin automatically without
even doing anything without thinking
because the price fluctuations in the
volatility
so when someone like elon knows he can
tweet and cause prices go crazy
you know for a fact that elon musk knew
when he tweeted this
it would drive the price down and all of
his friends did
and how many people that knew elon was
going to do this
sold their coins because how do you
track it sold at 58k
and then said okay elon you're good to
go elon posted it drops before it they
buy back in
yep and then elon sends a text i think
i'm going to pump doge today but he
doesn't say pump but you know what i
mean he's like on the phone and he's
like i'm gonna let people know i'm gonna
do this with the
and then they go and they buy that so
and then that rides
i i think bitcoin i i have a decent
amount of bitcoin i have a decent amount
of ethereum
and i have doge and i have cardano and
those are the things that i'm looking at
i think doge is inflationary i think
doge
is going to have value based on
confidence of the meme ability
elon might pump it up but i wouldn't at
like i wouldn't advocate for the
function of doge
it's just funny yeah it's 100 but uh
uh bitcoin ethereum and cardona are the
ones i do have that i do have confidence
in
and i've you know i think a lot of these
tokens are bunk
you got to be careful about tokens i
don't know if cardano is actually a
token
or if it's an actual crypto i think it's
its own crypto functions it's a proof of
state crypto like ethereum
but uh a lot of these tokens like shiba
i think sheba is a token right i don't
know i just saw it recently
um so tokens you can just click a button
boop you have tokens yeah i think it is
see i i don't know enough about tokens
uh tokens i'm gonna have to educate
myself on more so with
like uh with a cryptocurrency it's truly
decentralized like bitcoin yeah
you have you can create the code and
then start the program and then do the
proof of stake or proof of work to get
it
uh they can be centralized still even if
they're coins but bitcoins truly
decentralized
cardano is a utility token because it
helps to facilitate smart contracts
this is very convoluted to me yeah yeah
but but is it is it its own independent
blockchain like ethereum or is it
it's on its it's not on the ethereum
network so then i don't i don't think
it's actually a token
a token typically refers to someone goes
on a computer and presses enter and then
a bunch of tokens appear okay whereas
interesting the the coins
are like doge and bitcoin where you
do some work proof of work or proof of
stake to generate them
but i don't know maybe it's just
semantics yeah i got that info from
nasdaq.com
is that it was a token maybe i'm wrong
in my terminology there yeah
more crypto experts but i will say this
a lot of people
are first and foremost probably the the
main reason i'm saying these
these three tokens is because like when
you pull up coinbase or whatever they're
like the top listed or something
and so i'm looking at establishment
support and
i'm not going to pull up some no-name
token or crypto and be like oh that's
the one
yeah i think a lot of people do that
because they'll buy a bunch at a cheap
price and then try claiming this is the
one
i just went on coinbase and i was like
here's the top performing here's the top
you know like that people are looking at
and i was like all right i read about
them and i and i bought the clear
you know i got a quick uh explanation
from bitdegree.org
which i've never heard of before is this
bitcoin college yeah let's do this uh
the difference between a coin and a
token coins are native to their own
blockchain while tokens have been built
on top of another blockchain
right so i i don't think cardano is
built on another blockchain it's
interesting but i just saw it was a
token who knows maybe let's find let's
get the developers of cardano if you
guys are listening can i
be fake news yeah then maybe maybe i
don't i don't want it but i but i have
uh uh
a decent amount i don't i i went out
like years and years ago i bought a
bunch of ridiculous things
i think i have some other i think i
think i do have an account with like um
you know what bsv is or whatever i have
bitcoin cash only because bitcoin forked
and then you get bitcoin cash or
whatever
wasn't bsv like an overseas thing to buy
cryptos no uh it was it's it's a fork of
bitcoin
so basically there have been several
civil wars in bitcoin where
people are like this is not the true
vision of satoshi in the white paper so
i'm taking the existing network and
forking it off and it clones the network
but creates a separate coin
so if it happens and you're holding
bitcoin
the split you'll have equal amounts
bitcoin cash and bitcoin
and then people just made money
overnight yeah so this is the craziest
thing when when when bitcoin
and bitcoin cash forked all of a sudden
people's money doubled
like because now they had twice as many
coins yeah and then there was a weird
fluctuation between the two of people
trying to figure out which one was gonna
win and then bitcoin clearly took over
because bitcoin is bitcoin and
everything else is just claiming to be
something good or better
so anyway long story short regarding
this elon thing
i want to play a little juan williams
here i think maybe he really truly
believes that
it is destroying the environment there's
too much coal being burned and he wants
to
pressure the industry to move towards
renewables and he's he's using this as a
heavy hand
i i think i'm gonna i'm gonna i think
that's more of the mentality than
let's let's get but have you seen his
mining operations
like four tesla batteries i mean these
are not friendly at all to the
environment and i have a tesla i'm
saying this you know like
i'm fully honest about this but it's not
exactly environmentally friendly
how the batteries are made but on top of
that it was a few years ago
elon replied to somebody about the
output and the energy that it takes to
uh mine a bitcoin
and he actually agreed with them that it
was energy efficient that's
the that's the term they use so it's
interesting that he changed his mind now
when you know the mining practices have
only trended towards more energy
efficient since then
not less efficient it seems like people
have been in his ear yeah
that's what it feels like it feels like
somebody's actually pushing this
but i think he also has to be smart
enough with his platform his reach
his ability to shake the crypto market
you know
he's got to know that if you jump onto
something like this you're going to hurt
a lot of normal people
and that's the one warning i do have
about like doge to people is like yes
you can get really high returns
but if you're the type of person who's
not invested very much in your life
i would advise not getting involved
because you're very volatile and you can
get really scared when you have a dip
where it feels like oh my god i'm losing
25
of my savings or you can go to the
casino yeah if you want to play the game
so
uh uh bitcoin is a decentralized coin
so there's no one who has strong control
over it there's there's questions about
51
attacks and um quantum computing how
could be disruptive
ethereum is they're building software on
top of it cardano's basically the same
thing
i was just looking it up it's like the
co-founder created his own version of it
and the reason why i think ethereum is
so great is that they build programs on
top of it yeah
cardano is basically the same thing so
i'm looking at that and i'm like
all right you know i think these things
have a function more so than bitcoin but
bitcoin is still great
i'm not i'm not super interested in a
lot of these tokens where they're like
trying to claim it'll do something you
know other than
can you build programs on top of it so
there's a lot of tokens that exist
within the ethereum network and i'm
always like yeah but ethereum is the
is the main driver of all that so don't
take advice from me
you do you these are the things i'm
looking at and i'm [ __ ] so
don't listen to me because can i ask you
if i was real quick if i was a smart guy
out about bitcoin in 2011 when i kept
talking about every opportunity i had to
buy it i didn't
what do you think will happen when a
major government
like let's say our own or maybe germany
introduces their own digital
it's happening central bank
but i mean when it's out when it's out
and people can buy it
and it can be traded and it's on all the
different things
what do you think will happen to
everything else they'll go up in value
you think
everything will go up in value yeah so
uh
bitcoin if bitcoin goes up everything
goes up if bitcoin goes down everything
goes down
so this is from cnbc wall street banks
brace for digital digital dollars is the
next big disruptive force they're
talking about
a central bank digital currency i mean
dollars are already digital
there's just no blockchain for it it's
the banking ledgers that track
everything
so yeah but it's really for it's about
feeling like they are their own crypto
you know
which is actually why i would disagree
in terms of them riding up or down
together i think that when a government
a major government releases one of these
they're actually going to have an
inverse correlation where
when one is performing well the other
will perform not as well
and you know vice versa i think that
it's going to feel a little bit
more like their counterweights to each
other in a weird way
and i think it's they're hoping that
that's how it'll work
kind of like tether you follow tether at
all i i
i'm trying to understand what the um how
it would tie
in i knew a little bit about it like
tether is always
worth one u.s dollar and finance they're
both one dollar
yeah there's actually a lot of them now
um i think gusd
is one of them and uh there's there's
several now those would correlate really
well then
yeah and i would think that a central
bank token would be like that it would
always be worth it would be static value
and then all the other cryptos would
fluctuate around that you could always
get
uh uh dollars worth of that token
possibly or they would all ride
with almost like how the dollar works
now except for their hope would be
you know maybe there's a way to be able
to make that
more monetarily functional and also
beyond that
trackable you know like that's the real
goal they want to be able to see what
people are doing
yes um and i just i don't think they're
going to connect together in terms of
going up in value together
down in value together i think that
they're going to end up having a
correlation where one goes up one goes
down
we'll see as it is that's in the future
though that's coming if bitcoin goes up
tether although it says it stays at one
dollar
has gone down because bitcoin has gone
up they're relative to each other thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you